Dan.
Komputer kuantum sangat sensitif terhadap gangguan
yang menyebabkan kesalahan
dalam komputasinya, tapi penelitian terbaru menunjukkan
komputer kuantum berisik milik IBM menyamai metode klasik yang tepat
dan memverifikasi pada berbagai kondisi sambil menjalankan metode klasik canggih
aproksimasi di kedua kondisi yang bisa diverifikasi
maupun di kondisi yang tidak bisa diverifikasi
untuk eksperimen simulasi yang menantang.
Bagaimana cara mereka melakukannya? Mereka pakai teknik khusus
untuk menangani gangguan
dalam sistem kuantum yang disebut error mitigation.
Dengan teknik error mitigation ini
yang digunakan dalam eksperimen ini, kita jalankan kalkulasi kita
sambil perlahan-lahan menaikkan tingkat gangguan.
Lalu kita ekstrapolasi kembali ke kondisi tanpa gangguan.
Penelitian ini membawa kita selangkah lebih dekat ke komputasi kuantum yang berguna
kita